education education education some
people say that's the key to success in
this knowledge-based economy that we're
in and they're right but the reality is
the education model that we have
inherited today was built for the
farming economy and maybe the industrial
economy of the last century and so we're
gonna have to adapt it to meet the needs
of the next generation workforce and you
as members of the next generation
workforce are going to have to have your
own strategy for addressing how when
where and how much over the course of
your life of education you are going to
invest in let's start with early
childhood education and I'll start with
a story several months ago I was sitting
at a lunch with international students
here at MIT and they were mid-career
students and so I was sitting between
two mothers one from Portugal and one
from China and I asked him when did your
children start school in your countries
and once said right after I finished
maternity leave and the other said at
age three they were amazed to hear from
me that basically our children in this
country start in kindergarten at age
five unless there's some private
alternative well about 70% of the
industrialized world starts education
earlier so why is this so important well
let's take a look this is Professor
James Heckman from the University of
Chicago and Nobel prize-winning
economist and he is the world's expert
on the economics of early childhood
education he has studied this in
experiments he studied in Chicago he
studied it around the world and what he
finds is that there's a seven to ten
percent rate of return for society for
every year of early childhood education
that return is measured not only in
lifetime earnings its measured in lower
dropout rates less violence and less
criminal records the ability to achieve
one's objectives within one's career a
whole set of data tell us that getting
children into school early is very very
important to their success
well it's even more important for
children who are at risk inner-city
students from disadvantaged
neighborhoods have even higher rates of
return for early childhood education so
it's very clear that if we want to have
the next generations children well
educated so they can move on to achieve
their dreams in the workforce then we
have to get on with this the challenge
is that it's very expensive the good
news is that mayors and governors around
the country are beginning to recognize
the importance so from Seattle to New
York to Boston and many other cities
we're seeing mayor's take the lead and
saying let's figure out how we invest in
early childhood education and let's get
on with that task for individual parents
it is very expensive and so we have to
work together as a community to figure
out how we can fund early childhood
education for all and for every parent
it's critical that you think as you can
about what do you need what do your
children need what's appropriate for
different age groups from early
childhood right through elementary
school what can you afford and how can
you make it fit into your work and other
family responsibilities but if we don't
start early then we will pay the price
later
you